I'd love to give a Final Five if you'll do it with me,
'cause I just love to ask some rando questions.
All right, let's play.
All right, you ready?
Yeah.
It's time for the Final Five!
(audience cheering)
All right, so number one, you're in "Aquaman,"
but if you had a super power, what would it be?
It would be the ability to
fly.
I mean can I say that?
Can I still say fly?
Is it boring to say fly?
I don't think it would ever be
boring to fly.
It'd be so nice
to just be able to fly.
Like in the summertime I'd go on vacations whenever I want
without, you know, paying for the tickets.
That's what I wanna do.
I wanna fly to islands
in the summertime.
He wants to fly!
All right, number two,
give me your recent, random Google search.
(audience giggling)
What y'all laughing at?
How does time work?
Yeah.
I'm trying to figure out how time works.
I'ma tell you a piece of the truth.
All right, I was up last night
and I was trying
to figure out how time works.
Is there a reason?
Because sometimes you're just sitting there
and you're like, "Wait a minute, how does this all work?
And what if I could stop it?
And what if I can control this?"
And I was inspired to try to slow time down.
I'm still working on it, I still gotta figure it out.
Keep us posted.
I will.
See these are the answers you don't get otherwise.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay, number three, who was your first celebrity crush?
It was Tinker Bell.
(Drew laughing)
Was it the little ball on her tush?
Was it the little like fairy wings?
She flies!
I mean, she just had it all going on.
And then when you clap,
like I forget what happens
if you just clap for her.
Yeah.
She wanted her applause.
A strong woman who flies!
For a strong woman who flies
and who loves the sound of applause,
because that's nice too.
It's nice to be able to applaud your lady.
We like it here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Clap for each other, absolutely.
We're all very encouraging.
Number four, best mistake you've ever made?
I wanna say something about a recipe, right?
When I just like made a mistake and put the wrong seasoning
in some type of recipe and it turned out to be brilliant.
But I don't have that story.
No, but that's perfect.
Yeah.
'Cause you're right,
that's so relatable and inspired.
I love that answer.
Right, and then,
you just take credit for it and you say,
"I meant to do that."
Okay, number five, your pump up song right now?
"Du Hast" by Rammstein, anybody know it?
Yeah, there we go!
Okay, we're just cheering you on in work and in life.
"Ambulance" is in theaters starting April 8th.
You will fly and you will feel something
that most movies are not capable of making you feel.
I will say that.
So thank you so much.
I appreciate you.
(upbeat music)